corsican are nausea sorry who sees
himself as a youth icon and entertainer
post per the comments on the internet
his posts also refer to terror attacks
like the recent one in nice they receive
huge numbers of likes
well not yourself isn't all wrong
could you please come over here and just
explain to me what the state of
emergency is good for if someone can
still just drive his truck up onto the
sidewalk and kill 84 people thousands of
young core seconds follows here sarees
openly anti-islamic messages he says
there are too many Muslims on Corsica
and the many Moroccans who live in his
neighborhood on the outskirts of bastia
need to abide by the rules how lonely
the audacity the placing over all of us
look at the pies in our district even
dct a pillar Cena's sensitive here
Mickey yep so he won't bother do the
best job but that's not true the message
I didn't expect to file a perky titties
on this eBay if someone bothers someone
else here we don't hesitate to let them
know you Joe QVC yeah so cool episode
Shifu if that doesn't help them all I
can we use tougher methods santolli me
more than a fool you gets violent also
me man will be ethical polar we take
justice into our own hands all
Corrigan's are not blooded the cost is
all sure see sorry likes to portray
himself as a descendant of the FLN see
freedom fighters the Corsican
nationalists fought for more
independence from France for almost 40
years they wanted to preserve their own
language and cultural identity and
fought for more national rights
Zambian kuchi was one of them an armed
fighter some of his compatriots are
still serving long jail sentences he
says some young Corsican nationalists
are right-wing populist and have little
to do with his generations campaign my
philosophy in my platic ELISA my
philosophy is white self amply clear no
need for a community the Corsican people
share a common fate miss your PIPA
that'd be a real Corsican doesn't just
live on Corsica he needs to carry the
island in his heart that's more
important here than on the mainland
honky no and it goes for everyone he
Catholics Protestants and Muslims alike
a Tunisian mo Bianca she only ended the
armed opposition to the government in
Paris two years ago it wasn't an easy
decision but the movement had been
weakened and had been infiltrated by the
mafia and Paris was paying more
attention to Corsica with talk of
negotiations on independence today bian
qu Chi is the head of an autonomous
fraction in Parliament that is opposed
to violence he wants to make Corsica a
model of tolerant society she on Parkin
is and ocotilla so to dilute reward if
if someone lives in a corner deny risk
rejecting others phenomena huije and
will end up in a crisis that is no
longer controllable Kanu polka famiiies
he not everyone welcomes his change of
policy some see the fact that a former
freedom fighter is now looking for a
peaceful solution as treachery WOB
person most post Korsakov Yap I don't
approve say Pavia was good but special
offers irrespective measured no call to
cease fire dude something's was on Goss
well he sort of war he sort up all back
then they made sure nobody could simply
do as they please let the nose pasquese
now they've laid down their weapons to
appear in a good light but in reality
there are still some who were prepared
to fight why he stood or at the end of
April this Muslim prayer room in Ajaccio
burned down after a breakin the Muslims
immediately suspected nationalists were
to blame and even if the police cannot
confirm that their fear continues why
don't you try work with course again
soldiers I grew up with course against
hate with him played soccer with memo I
am a course was in kids off to war cos
the felon wanted to do
do any good what all this sudden hatred
worries us upon a funny we're afraid for
our wives and children our families and
the feeling is unbearable the joy of you
the young right-wing nationalists want
to see results
a secret splinter group of the FLN see
recently announced it was prepared to
bear arms this time against is a sign
that be on coochie and his famous
Aquatica supporters are losing their
influence Jin Xiu en que busca Liu Bei
I'm worried that the French government
will be deaf to all of our demands
even if we reach a unanimous decision
wha-hoo unanimity we know that would
lead to a return to violence santa
Osetra be on camera on the near your
defend amend of your loans and that
would be a huge problem
yes ma ma la on suhasi Domini
the Vallecito SEO still so far beyond
coot he refuses to declare the Corsican
nationalist political experiment of
failure he sees it as his task to
reunite young and old nationalists